siete de la mañana en la reserva de anís
y está a 400 km de abiyán a cada vez que
el safari se va deuda entristece desde
hace 22 años tiene la misma preocupación
que los visitantes no puedan ver a los
animales del parque es como la casa
todos los días se gana
pero pronto nada
es un joven macho las hembras no tienen
cuernos una especie de antílope
desaparecido del paisaje marfileño a la
que se puede acercar la familia están en
manada y hay otros más adelante
uno puede encontrar el cobo y el búfalo
incluso amigos especialmente el mono a
patas franco marfileña afincada en
abiyán inés ve por primera vez estos
animales y en costa de marfil yo no
sabía que teníamos este tipo de reservas
con expertise oro natural que no
explotamos en absoluto cuando se habla
de costa de marfil la gente piensa
directamente en lo más natural
el cacao los marañones y en realidad no
también tenemos cosas como ésta que son
simplemente alucinantes si la existencia
de un safari es sorprendente en costa de
marfil es por la deforestación masiva
que ha afectado al país el 90% de los
bosques de costa de marfil han
desaparecido en los últimos 60 años y
con ellos la mayor parte de la vida
animal este proyecto de conservación es
obra de un empresario franco marfileño
de costillo esto inspirado en los visor
sudafricanos su convicción el turismo
animal es la única forma de recaudar
fondos para la conservación de los
animales
sudáfrica recibe 2 millones de turistas
al año por el turismo de naturaleza
se ve en tanzania en todas partes así
que por qué no en áfrica occidental
cuando se creó el parque finales de la
década de 1990 los animales habían
abandonado el bosque del río anís y tras
22 años de conservación la fauna vuelve
poco a poco pero la diversidad de
animales está lejos de restablecerse por
completo como una especie en peligro de
extinción
aller omnipresente en costa de marfil
ahmet un elefante de 13 años vive aquí
en semilibertad en una zona de 20
hectáreas la amet como estas después de
un periodo más agita la eterna caudal
para la estuvo huyendo durante más de un
año dawn la de bilardo y rompieron a
cabo en los pueblos de los alrededores
estropeando los campos y fue acorralado
para enviarlo de vuelta a su zona
para que pudiera ser protegido y tener
descendencia
la desaparición de paquidermos en costa
de marfil ha alarmado a la comunidad
científica durante décadas hace 40 años
tres mil elefantes estaban en el
territorio en la actualidad hay unos 200
deuda conocía el momento en el que
podían encontrarse en la naturaleza la
población ha disminuido mucho en
comparación con los años 70 ahora rara
vez los vemos este es silvestre no es de
la sabana
el parque previene los conflictos entre
humanos y animales pero la distancia con
las viviendas no es suficiente para
proteger a la fauna hoy en día la caza
furtiva sigue siendo sin duda la
principal amenaza para los animales de
la reserva ni sí que el principal
enemigo de los guardias encargados de
vigilar la zona que nunca salen sin su
rifle
estamos en conflicto con los cazadores
furtivos nunca se sabe
frente al kiel intenté hacer algo yo
también tengo que defenderme en la
estación seca el bosque se vuelve
transitable y las incursiones de los
cazadores furtivos son numerosas
cuando tomamos el camino vemos los
platos de la gente todos usamos el mismo
tipo de zapato y lo reconocemos
fácilmente así que si se ven rastros de
zapatos diferentes eso demuestra que hay
un cazador a veces se oye un disparo y
gracias a eso nos podemos agarrar por
sorpresa seleccionados entre los
habitantes de los pueblos vecinos los
guardias suelen ser antiguos cazadores
hoy en día hay más de 30 de ellos que se
turnan para vigilar las 41 mil hectáreas
de la reserva día y noche el interés
forma el terreno era complicado antes va
a haber un solo animal aquí hay que
esperar durante meses había muchos
cazadores
barahoneros historias
carbonell
aunque los pastores de ganado y los
carboneros en busca de leña han dejado
de entrar en la reserva ahora son los
mineros de oro los que vienen a
contaminar las aguas esa noche cuatro
personas fueron detenidas en un sitio
del lavado de oro luís diakité sale a su
encuentro cuando te pagan 5 francos al
mes por venir a acabar y son ustedes los
que también se convierten en cazadores
furtivos no son cazadores que vienen a
menudo estos jóvenes fueron detenidos
por soldados de la oficina de parques y
reservas de costa de marfil que se
encontraban en el lugar
cada vez es peor en los últimos años
hemos visto un aumento de la extracción
ilegal de oro los cazadores furtivos ya
eran un problema
pero los buscadores de oro son aún
peores las amenazas al medio ambiente
son enormes
el 70% de nuestro gasto se destina a la
protección del medio ambiente la
protección
para hacer frente a estas amenazas se
construirá una valla electrificada de
100 kilómetros alrededor de la reserva
la defensa de la fauna en costa de
márfil es una batalla que está lejos de
terminar